- Let's not have a Howie-kioke
How about a Kellyoke encore?
I love those.
Here's Kelly and her band, y'all,
with "Sucker" by the Jonas Brothers.
Watch this.
(audience cheering)
♪ Whoa ♪
♪ We go together ♪
♪ Better than birds of
a feather, you and me ♪
♪ We change the weather, yeah ♪
♪ I'm feeling heat in December
when you're 'round me ♪
♪ I've been dancing on top of
cars and stumbling out of bars ♪
♪ I follow you through the
dark, can't get enough ♪
♪ You're the medicine and the pain ♪
♪ The tattoo inside my brain ♪
♪ And, baby, you know it's obvious ♪
♪ I'm a sucker for you ♪
♪ You say the word and I
will follow you anywhere ♪
♪ I'm a sucker for you ♪
♪ Any road you take, you
know that you'll find me ♪
♪ I'm a sucker for all
the subliminal things ♪
♪ No one knows about you ♪
♪ About you ♪
♪ And you're making the typical
me break my typical rules ♪
♪ It's true, I'm a sucker for you, hey ♪
♪ I've been dancing on top of
cars and dancing out of bars ♪
♪ I follow you through the
dark, can't get enough ♪
♪ You're the medicine and the pain ♪
♪ The tattoo inside my brain ♪
♪ And, baby, you know it's obvious ♪
♪ I'm a sucker for all
the subliminal things ♪
♪ No one knows about you ♪
♪ About you ♪
♪ And you're making the typical
me break my typical rules ♪
♪ Hey, I'm sucker for you ♪
(audience cheers)
(Kelly chuckles)